[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a little bit about what I'll talk
about in this talk which is called
person diverse healthcare data is we'll
talk a little bit about the challenges
in healthcare data we'll talk about a
framework that we built for parsing all
this healthcare data and airflow how we
integrate this data with data science
and healthcare operations and how we
actually use this to drive better
outcomes with our patients so a quick
real quick overview of what help of what
clover health is clover health is
Medicare Advantage insurance company so
we actually operate as Medicare and we
did this on the East Coast and our
mission is to be an entirely new
approach to healthcare so we're a
startup we're backed by a number of
investors here we operate currently out
of New Jersey and we're headquartered in
SF and totally venture-backed what we
try to do differently than most
healthcare insurance companies or most
Medicare Advantage companies is that
we're very much a technology and a
data-driven
startup built around healthcare data so
our goal is that we can use that data to
both lower costs and improve outcomes
for our patients in healthcare so this
all sounds really good but what are the
challenges like why hasn't anybody else
on this why isn't your insurance company
today doing this and the reason for that
we're will start talking about the
challenges with healthcare data is
typically healthcare data with health
insurance companies it's spread across
multiple disparate systems it's not just
clinical data that you might find in EMR
systems but it's also data that you'll
find in claims authorization utilization
management appeals grievances provider
data typically in most insurance
companies these are entirely separate
software products there's some
integration maybe between them but
typically if you want to connect data
between these different systems which
are often stored in different databases
in different sections of America
sometimes you typically use people so
someone has to go in and query the data
and then has to go into another system
pull that data together and build up
some report and this builds a lot of
inefficiencies in healthcare operations
today and also it makes it really
hard to try to use like machine learning
or any of the more modern technologies
to try to predict patient outcomes or
events so clover tries to really
centralize our data for healthcare data
so this actually just caused a lot of
concern with people and this is a couple
of samples not from us but of where
people have been upset about their
healthcare company for a variety of
reasons and um in all of these examples
it's really tied to the central fact
that data is siloed so this is from
American Medical Association who
complaints typically about high time
between utilization raids little
communication between providers this is
one from Kevin MDS one of the more
common social blogs for doctors where
the they did this exhaustive um analysis
and the help company never could find it
even though they sent it to them on SMTP
servers and then a lot of times most
healthcare providers actually have from
Medicare Advantage have 30 to 60% of
their provider offices have errors with
it which is pretty higher rate so clover
doesn't want to have these problems but
we still get a large amount of data and
again it's not just clinical and EMR
data which people typically think about
we get data from pharmacies we get data
labs that are separate from the clinical
data EMR sales data because we are
selling and going out and selling this
insurance we offer our members gym
memberships so we actually have
measurements on their gym usage claims
of course support tickets and then
there's public data sources which comes
from CMS which is Medicare so we get
about 300 different kinds of files in
tons of different formats some are more
modern sometimes like send us some
things we can use an API and pull that
in in a nice JSON format but a lot of
times we have to work with some really
old formats so EDI and x12 which is over
here which is lovely to look at and
COBOL flat files if you've ever seen
those those are pretty ubiquitous in
health care because COBOL still runs a
lot of these older systems so we have
about 40 different vendors right now
that we received at
from and that's growing by about two
vendors a month and we have they all
have their unique formats and even when
they use something like CSV those
sometimes have multiple styles of CSV in
one CSV or some interesting ways of
putting structure into you know very
flat format so clever needs to deal with
this so what we developed was what we
call the clover parsing framework and
just to give a little bit of a short
history of how we kind of got to this
this point is we're relatively new
backing generated 2015 we really did not
have any parsing we had kind of an ETL
process and people would just have to
manually load it into a database and
obviously if you're working with some of
those older COBOL like files it can be
not so fun so then in June of 2015 we
created an initial framework and we
built this entirely in Python but as we
started growing more and more files we
realized that while it's very flexible
maybe this framework for an engineer to
add more file types
it wasn't flexible for data science or
for operations to add more file types
and we get about 300 so we can't just
devote engineering resources to just
parsing all day long so in April 2016 we
realized we needed something a little
bit more robust and and then we've
started to roll that out over since
summer in fall of 2016
so a quick overview technically of what
it is we have built it in air flow and
air flow is a task management system
that allows you to build DAGs or
dielectric acyclic graphs I'm probably
pronouncing that horribly wrong and I
know we have a few our flow people here
on the end so and we built in an air
flow because it really gives a lot of
visibility to us and the three main
parts of our parsing system is one to
classify it and then to actually parse
it where we actually pull it out of the
file and then the third is to load it
and load it could be either into the
data warehouse or other systems out
there and so really throughout all these
processes here we actually use a
specification that actually determines
how we're going to parse the file what
type of file it should be and
what do we expect so talking a little
bit about airflow we've been using
interflour for quite a while and so the
big reason we chose airflow this is one
of their spiritual so that was actually
that really visibility it is a UI and we
don't want data science or operations
that have to go into logs or have to go
deep into you know like SSH into a box
to find a log or maybe Caban or
something else there you know there's
plenty of ways to view logs but it's not
as clean and efficient as this so you
can actually see the whole this is not
our test this is just a screenshot but
you can actually see you know all the
different tasks within there and you can
click on those and you can get a log you
can also see whether they failed or
succeeded so having that was really
important to us for giving that
visibility data science and operations
again we've been using it the visibility
is great you can create these very
complex process and chains of things
which is really important to us so we
actually built kind of a framework on
top of the airflow and we actually use
it in multiple processes so the parsing
primer isn't used in just one section of
tasks and that's it it's actually used
in multiple different processes and we
can even do it in a little bit of a
streaming fashion which air flow isn't
quite built for but we kind of modified
it to do that and so we can use it in
multiple pipelines so it really is a
framework that we kind of built so the
first thing we do before we kind of put
it through that three-tiered parsing
system is we have to receive the data
there's kind of two ways we do this one
is where is kind of more instant and one
is where it's kind of more you know we
pull every so often typically with
external api's or external SFTP s we
don't pull every two seconds so because
we would probably hit limits or with
similar vendors we might break their
servers but whereas our own SFTP servers
we typically receive files from our
vendors in SFTP which is kind of I think
a little odd but it's very efficient and
that's kind of how healthcare works
today and so we typically receive these
in SMTP servers but we actually use that
in combination with like an s3 file
system so when they drop a file
to our SMTP servers we immediately get
it and we actually save every version of
the file which has actually been really
important because we've noticed people
try to change it real quick for some
interesting situations so in between all
those three processes in the parsing we
actually have built kind of a
centralized kind of source and objects
that flow through all those different
parts the data source typically
represents something like an API or an
SFTP server any of the sources that we
receive it and then the data objects
represent a single file and all of those
get synced up to s3 so we're constantly
saving state in this database so as I
talked about before we kind of when we
went to set off to build this was to
make this more flexible so when we built
the first parsing system at Clover a few
years ago basically it was all Python
and the problem with something being all
Python is typically need someone who
knows Python to fix it or change it or
tweak it and as we started adding files
this became very this became actually a
bit of a strain on engineering resources
so what we did in this new version was
we actually have kind of a two layered
system one is kind of what you might say
is a yellow layer and that's where you
actually define a spec in yellow and
within these specifications that will
show one in a minute here you can
actually define what the file looks like
what's kind of the columns or structures
depending on the actual type of file you
can do various type conversions cleanup
things like that all within kind of this
file that just gets read and basically
translated into code the nice thing
about that is for data science and
operations you don't have to know all
about the internals of the parsing
system you can just edit a yamo file we
have lots of lots of people in
operations so this is very helpful for
when they want to add a new file or
change one or a vendor has something
they want tweaked and they have to
change it and then underneath that we
have kind of a Python layer which is
very reusable code you can parse just
about anything with that layer and it's
all built around like abstract base
classes but again like operation stuff
science doesn't have to know about that
layer in order to
Changez so what does this kind of look
like we can parse a whole bunch of files
with this CSV EDI and so it kind of
looks like this you specify the classify
and so you kind of specify where it's
actually coming in this is from
SilverSneakers which is the gym
membership that we offer to our members
and they actually send this like nice
little source here and sometimes we can
modify that and things but in this case
we're just going to accept it as it is
and then whoever wrote this spec here I
just took it from them
basically they specify that it's an XLS
that we only want one particular sheet
that has a header and then basically
kind of type conversion across all those
different items within there this is a
pretty basic one it can obviously be
much more complex especially with you
know maybe something like DDA or hl7 is
a little bit different but really in
this case is really easy for someone to
take one of these in this case the
vendor just drops an excel file it's
really easy for them just to specify hey
we expect to see a file like this coming
in it's going to look like this let's
parse it in this manner and then of
course we do alert anytime that's we
think it's going to come in like this
and it doesn't so a couple things we
just turn this on so we're not parsing
huge amounts of data these days but is
growing quite rapidly over time we
archive quite a bit of files and parse
about 4,000 per week in seven gigabytes
the difference between those two amount
of gigabytes per week is because we also
have images and call logs which don't
get parse so our bigger tables we have
about 1 million separate claims at
Clover which is quite a bit we have lots
of pharmacy data so every transaction or
pharmacy we pretty much have all that
data and it's only about three hundred
and sixteen gigabytes now that that's
because we've only just turned it on
started putting more and more data but
it does scale very very nicely into
multiple terabytes which we've tested
out so we're just slowly turning that on
this way we don't have some amazing new
two numbers here to show you but it does
scale very nicely so the next thing to
kind of talk about here a little bit
briefly
is there any other health care companies
here any chance oh wait one okay so just
a few things about compliance this makes
it a little bit harder for us through
all these systems everything we do has
to be any like vendor that we use has to
be covered under BIA agreements and so
one of the ways we kind of have found it
to be really efficient to make sure we
are compliant with requirements for
storing patient medical records is to
use s3 it's encrypted in transit and at
rest and which is the one of the key
principles of compliance in healthcare
so really we've found to be s3 is a
really helpful resource and in between
all those different steps of data of the
parsing framework we're actually sinking
up to s3 and back to s3 so it's a really
easy way to store our data compliantly
as far as things we've kind of learned
through this make sure you always have a
baa with any of the which is the
business agreements that you have to
have for storing healthcare data on a
third party and make sure you're always
watching where your logs are metadata go
because they could contain patient
health care information and then also
one of the things that we kind of have
built into kind of a downstream of this
Pricer framework is to validate the data
we receive we have had times where we
have gotten data we're not supposed to
have yet for vendors um so anyway so the
next part is how do we kind of integrate
this with data science and operations so
we can't actually automate everything
unfortunately with this framework one of
the things that's kind of important here
is that typically a lot of our files do
get dropped under these SFTP servers by
people so although clover wants to
automate this and doesn't want a person
pulling down a file opening it up
parsing out manually that's how a lot of
our vendors actually do kind of work and
so there's a lot of times where there's
someone dropping the file onto an SFTP
server that then we receive so the
problem is we can't just give like a
feedback loop where we're just returning
you like err this file doesn't look
right you know check it in your system
typically they just drop the file and
that's it they they think they're done
then that's final so it's really
important that we we need some sort of a
feedback
so it was really important in building
this that we actually kind of have a
human element where we're tying it back
with staff members in our operations and
in our insurance operations teams some
of the ways we do that is one with
airflow because it has great visibility
we can show that page to operations team
and they can see if something doesn't
get parse quite right another thing that
we can do that we do to kind of well
this is going to actually skip to one
more and they'll come back so another
thing that we do to also do this is a
lot of monitoring so we have a lot of
within that specification that you have
that we have is really easy for us to
add various like operations team in this
case I just put my email here but we can
put numerous people from our operations
team and alert them based on a couple
different special metrics of data
there's just two here like how late was
the data or anything like that
but we can do a whole variety of special
monitoring around when the data received
and the alerting for that and so this is
really important having that go back to
the operations team who then have the
contacts with the vendors you can say we
got a weird file or the files are coming
late or something like that another way
that we do is is UI's to us are really
important actually in in data science
because again we have not just our
science we have operations people who
are fairly technical and and can do a
lot of things and so one of the things
we do I think mode is a sponsor here to
is use mode and airflow and lots of
different ways to kind of allow people
to easily build their own little UI so
mode you can just query and then build
charts and other kind of little web
pages airflow gives us visibility in the
actual parsing so all of these things
really give visibility for a data
science team and that really brings down
the amount of workload that we have to
give our engineers the engineers don't
have to monitor this as much as they
would if it was entirely you know with
no UIs and only just logs and
Association into boxes so we talked
about monitoring so now we'll talk a
little bit about improving outcome so we
have this data there's lots of things we
can do with it
we can connect a lot of the data
together claims data with maybe more
clinical data or lab data and we can
really combine them together so this one
we've shown before at a few conferences
but basically smaller is better and this
is medication adherence and we don't
have an updated chart but it has
continued to trend downward which is
good but basically right around in here
in the middle of the chart we actually
started to ingest a particular kind of
new files that allowed us to better
track and then we started a campaign
right after that which allowed us to
actually target members who were not
adherent to their medication which is a
huge which is a huge concern members who
aren't you know hearing their medication
or much more likely to be hospitalized
or have a variety of issues and so we
really want to get ahead of that because
that can be very beneficial to the
member improve their outcomes and cut
our costs of course
so throughout all of that we can
actually bring it down by having these
multiple files come together one of the
key important things here is that
latency is really killer if if we had
really high latency zhan receiving these
different kinds of files
we'd have all sorts of false positives
and false negatives and it would be
really hard for us to figure out which
members are actually not compliant with
their medications which would make it
very hard for us to then drive clinical
outreach to help them become compliant
with their medications we make it really
easy to connect the information this is
demo there's no thi our patient health
care information here is we actually
threw out our if you call into clover or
if you're one of the operations people
we actually have an internal UI which is
pretty robust and it's really easy to
drill down into all the different
sections so in this case if you're
looking at our providers really easy to
see they're off their appeals or claims
you can see how they're connected you
can drill down into the patient you can
look through all the patient's
information so it's really easy if
someone calls up and has a question that
you really do have the answer right then
and there which is a huge complaint from
providers and physicians today with
healthcare
information the other thing is clover
actually sends nurses to our patients
homes so if they're not compliant with
their medication or things like that or
they've just been discharged from the
hospital or something like that we we
actually do send nurses out to their
home to kind of offer more care and so
the nurses actually have a whole view of
the patient from the labs to their
clinical data to their claims their
complaints or grievances information
about their providers and so when the
nurse actually goes to their home they
have a really complete history and view
of the patient and their health more
than their own physician actually maybe
would in certain cases so it really
actually does drive us to to really have
to make our members healthier and to
drive better outcomes so here's like a
small case study how that all kind of
fits in this is from Bloomberg article
about us but they're talking about one
patient of ours who was in his 80s and
he was hospitalized after a fall frail
leg ulcers type 2 diabetes used a walker
and we were able to in this article
based on a risk profile that he would
fall again that he had an increased
possibility of falling again and so when
he was discharged we actually alerted a
member to his house who actually
realized he was getting in out of bed
with this step stool in this very unsafe
manner and we actually installed like a
bed rail on that but how does that
actually come in with the parsing system
really in reality we have to know in
order to do this accurately with low
latency we have to know a lot of
information we have to know that this
patient was hospitalized we have to know
his prior diagnosis we have to know that
you know he has all these different
conditions which sounds easy but it's
actually quite hard to predict and so
really we have to bring all of these
pieces of data together and so with the
parsing system that's really where the
rubber hits the road and where we really
do deliver on bringing all that into our
system very quickly and then it's
actually pretty easy although it's much
bigger and we could talk for four days
about like all the things that happen
after we ingest data but it actually
makes it quite a bit easier once you
have all the data in a central data
warehouse
to actually make those connections and
find yes this patient is actually a risk
for falling again let's send a nurse to
his home which happened in this article
anyway I got through that pretty quickly
um so that's kind of the end of my
presentation one shameless little
mentioned clover is starting they're
kind of late spring early summer hiring
so if you're a data engineer or a data
scientist and you want to do something
that you know works with the healthcare
data and gives back to patients every
single day and has a lot of social value
let us know um so as always and that's
about it so thank you and then I think
we have time for questions questions yes
sir yes yeah operations here
non-programmers can edit the ML file
like configuration is code so how do you
version it
that's a good question uh so there is
actually so there is I didn't show it up
there but there is a way to do a version
parser of that yeah Moe file so you can
specify multiple versions across
multiple files for that and the system
on the internal will take that and parse
it according to that different version
and it is also all in github so they
have access to push it in so we do keep
track of the version history that way as
well but the file anything else
I was wondering if you could go I didn't
quite get if you go in a little bit more
detail about how you the layer that you
wrote on top of air flow and how you and
what that does sure so is this kind of
you're not talking about the yeah Malloy
you're talking about kind of the
framework around air flow for this
correct yeah yeah so what it does so it
works in a couple different ways for the
most part this is like very reusable
coke components so it can go into
multiple tasks with an airflow was kind
of the first way in which we approach
this because we didn't want it just to
be used in one task in air flow so we
actually because they're fully you can
generate the structure the dag structure
via code we actually have kind of
pre-built functions that you can say
these are the files I want to parse give
me all the tasks and then here's the
start and end task of those tasks in the
dag and so you can kind of swap in and
push it into it a little bit into the
DAGs then the other thing that we kind
of did with some of these files we we
get it and some of them you know if
they're parse within 12 hours it's fine
but other times we want it kind of more
streaming baits which air flow is really
a batch processing system so what we
actually do is we we have ways at which
we can trigger a dag run once the file
received so in that sense a run in air
flow is kind of a callback and I know
that's not something typically done in
air flow but I do know a few companies
who are doing that and something we do
so yeah
just a quick follow-up to that so you
were saying I came in really late okay
you're saying that the you can trigger a
dagger run but what causes that
triggering happen do you have another
say in listening or what like what yeah
in that case
yeah there's kind of a listening dad
controller dag I think is what some I
think a few companies is you know a
controller dag and it's basically kind
of like a little event loop and so it's
kind of can watch the file and when it
shows up then it triggers another dag so
it's kind of I've noticed that become a
pattern and air flow with a few people I
don't know if that's necessarily the
best way to do it I know there's an API
and the works for that as well so maybe
we could use it a little differently but
yeah we kind of have as dag as an event
loop that does that and trigger set and
the dag what is it watching kind of in
the deck itself well then the dag is
basically always kind of constantly
running and so you have a dag and then
it's like REIT rigging itself right
after the end of it we could do that I
think in general it's easier and cleaner
to see when it actually ran and just see
one run for the file and see it as kind
of a callback but yeah you could use it
if you wanted to